hello youtube just Louis reference this
is wins in here and welcome to the
second part of my chest recruit are
against ephone now in this section I'm
going to cover when your opponent place
defy and grab more space on the Queen
side well certainly here black will play
Knight to e7 and you can see I have
highlighted by the arrows over here why
it has so many choices but the good part
from the black perspective is against
each of them our plan of campaign is
pretty much similar now what I have done
in this video is I will show you piece
layout and the theory of this lie and
then we will see some of my own games
which will illustrate how you can go for
the win in this kind of positions so
here black has a two choices especially
if you are a Kings Indian player and you
like a Kings Indian structure then there
is a one easy way you can get a very
advantageous Kings in structure so it
runs like this so black plays d6
followed by g6 and then Google it up
goes to the g7 and now black plays these
amazing move which is Fi normally in
Kings in structure black plays Knight to
f6 first and then this Knight goes
somewhere let's say it goes to the
either H Phi or yate and then black
pushes their v so in a way it knows one
tempo but here fi comes straight away
directly and that way black can say one
tempo and that can be very very
effective
the further line can run like this so
black will play Knight to f6 and
castling on the King side with normal
Kings in your theory now in this video I
have not covered the system because I
don't play off on Kings engine so if you
want to play this system then you better
learn the theory of the Kings in this
structure
the other line which I'm going to
recommend here is this one let's say
here white will play Knight to c3 and
then we'll play Knight to g6 so if you
calculate the moves over here
what black has done is this Knight goes
from b8 to the g6 so it hasn't shifted
on the Kings side and the last more of
the black is just free of this Bishop
and I'll show you the main theory or the
idea behind this line so what black
wants to do is put the bishop on b4 and
if white allows then black wants to
capture this Knight and giving black a
double pole so you can see the spawns
right now is our double and we want to
block the Queen side of the white and
then we are concentrating on the King
side attack and that is the pretty much
plan of the plan so let's see how the
pieces can be placed so first of all
what we are going to do is we will play
d6
followed by the Knight to f6 so you can
see the Knight to f6 is gaining time on
the phone so White has to defend that
pawn somehow so most logical way is
Bishop to d3 and then we are going to
castle on the Kings side here we have
very simple idea we want to put one of
the night on the f4 and there are two
ways you can do it the first way if you
open and does not allow nice to h5 then
you can play at 6:00 and then after
night - at 7:00 you can look forward for
the push of f4
and the second way you can do is you can
play straight away if you open allows
this so you can play Knight to h5 and
then light slot into the very beautiful
square by 2 F 4 and then this plan is
very simple you want to push the F pawn
so after F file let's say white catches
over here one pair of bishop has been
captured you can see the F file has been
open up and the Queen has X F excess of
either f6 G Phi or h4 so let's say here
Queen goes h4 and other who can join the
party and we have very slow but very
effective attack going on on the King
side and you will see in my games most
of my opponents are helpless against
this plan there is one important concept
that you should remember in this theory
is let's say if meantime white goes on
the Queen side let's say play see for
then you should do not allow these pawns
to go forward so one way to do is you
play b6 so now you can see this Square
has been blocked and if white still
insists to open up the game with the
move a4 then we are going to play a file
and you can see this lovely pawn chain
so starting from ePHI who goes to the a5
and it's cramping the whole Queen side
of the white and that means if the Queen
side has been blocked we can concentrate
on the White King side
and that is very very effective plan so
I hope you understand the theory and now
I'm going to show you some of my own
game which will show you how you can
implement this theory and the practice
now the first move which we want to deal
is the space getting move which is c4
and this is the most likely a chances
when you open and grab more space with
the Moody file well against this you
should go with our recommended plan so
you will play Knight to g6 and idea is
very simple this Bishop will go either
to c5 or goes to the p4
in my first game my opponent reply with
Knight to c3 and here I pin this Knight
and in this game
my opponent responded with Knight to f3
so you can see by doing this more order
white is allowing black to capture this
Knight
so we should certainly capture this
Knight and giving white a double pawn
and now it's time to play d6 so stopping
any sea fire once here my opponent
responded with Bishop to d3 and I play
Knight to f6 and now my opponent castle
on the Kings side and I Castle on the
Kings side and now hear my opponent
played this move which is Bishop to g5
so try to pinning the nine it's a good
time to kick this bishop so I played at
six please load bishop cannot go to the
h4 because it was simply captured by the
knight so my in this game my opponent
plays Bishop to e3 his planning is very
simple he wants to push this car to the
c5 please remember this is very very
important whenever white wants to expand
on the Queen side we should stop this so
we have to play this move which is b6 so
now that pawn has been locked and now my
upper and play this move which is rook
to d1 I don't know what's his intention
but it's just like a prophylactic move
now here comes a very good move which is
Knight wedge file now whenever you play
Knight to h5 you need to keep in mind
that this epon you're a pawn is in under
attack but right now it is very very
safe the reason is because why it has a
loose bishop on d3 here white cannot
play this move which is Knight to e5
because if we play Knight to e5 it looks
like a gaining a pawn but after Knight
cross ePHI
it's white which lose a piece after the
whole exchange so whenever this Bishop
is lose on d3 you can certainly look
forward for a night to Edgehill so
keeping in mind that way my opponent
plays Queen to d2 and now my wonderful
light has been posted on their phone and
if you can manage your night to put on
f4 that means 50% of your game as did
one here my opponent strangely preserve
their Bishop so he played Bishop to c2
and you know the plant yep it's a five
so now we are opening up the F file my
opponent plays a4 and I played a5 and if
you remember this is the structure we
were talking about in the theory so now
I have completely locked the Queen side
of the white that means white cannot do
anything on the Queen side and that is
the area of play of white if white
cannot do anything on the Queen side
white has to sit and watch the black
attack and hope that black make mistake
which we are not going to do after a if
I my upon responded with h4 which is a
kind of mistake and this kind of mistake
will happen if you block him like this
and can you spot here the wonderful moon
yep it's Knight cross g2 and after King
cross g2 we have mu F Phi that means
regaining a piece with a better pawn
structure and my opponent plays rook to
h1 so trying to defending that pawn
because it was attacked by night and the
Queen but here I capture the bishop and
after Queen captures I played Bishop to
g4 so again attacking the knight
my opponent carelessly played this move
which is Bishop to diva and can you spot
it it's more or less games over so I
simply capture that night and after
forcefully White has to recapture with
the bishop
I simply play Knight cross H for white
lose a piece so my opponent plays King
to have fun but after very simple route
cross f3 Queen to e2 and rook to f5 I
simply emerge without piece and upon up
and my opponent resign over here so that
is one game which perfectly match to a
theory and that's why I have included as
an opening game
now in the second game of c4 line it's
very very instructive because my
opponent was an FM so I play Knight to
g6 so idea is very simple I want to play
Bishop to b4 and my opponent responded
with Knight to c3 and I played Bishop to
b4 but instead of last game my knight to
f3 this time f1 plays Bishop to d2 so he
clearly understand the positional damage
which blackened does to the fighter here
there is a one small trap that black
should avoid if you carelessly play move
such as d6 then you will lose a piece
with Queen to e4 check so please
remember this whenever your Bishop is on
b4 you never play this d6 so you will
wait you'll probably Castle first and
then probably play d6 but when your
Bishop is on b4 now play d6 here I
played Knight to f6 so attacking the
pawn and Y just defined it with Bishop
to d3 and I played castle the Kings side
and my opponent responded with a 3 so I
capture the night and why do we capture
with the bishop so you can see that way
white does not allow black to damage
this pawn structure now the less we
continue with our main line so I played
e6 and my opponent responded with Knight
to e2 so the logic is very simple white
wants to push f4 before black plays fi
but here s power theory it's very simple
so we are going to play Knight to h5 so
we are not only stopping blacks f4 by
black himself is preparing the move f5
here
my opponent castle on the kingside and I
played Knight to f4 again the wonderful
square for the knight my opponent
captured the night and I recaptured with
the undenied and here he played Queen to
f3 now this is a one lose move I can say
because it's provoking the fi which I
infected it so I play their fight and
here he captured I recapture with the
bishop and after Bishop exchanged my
opponent plays Bishop to d2 so right now
his idea is very simple because this
night does not have any good discoveries
so he just want to improve the bad his
bad bishop nevertheless I played Queen
to f6 so idea is very simple
I want to slant the screen to the g6 and
then the other group can joined into the
FF it and as per the theory this will be
a wonderful position for the black hear
my opponent responded with rook to c1 so
probably he wants to push this guy to c5
I played Queen to g6 so now I'm trying
some cheapos based on the pin G to pawn
so my opponent capture this night so I
recapture and then he plays Queen to g3
so he wants to exchange the pin well if
the Queen has been exchanged then white
is doing fine but I didn't allow him so
I played first of all rook to g4 so his
Queen has been attacked so he played
Quint Westry and now I played this move
which is route to f8
and my all three major pieces are lining
to the scheme here my opponent responded
with f3 and I played Luke to d4 so
planning is very very simple Luke want
to penetrate on the second rank of the
opponent enemy king and my opponent
decided to again offer me the Queen
trade which I declined with this move
which is Queen to d3 now you can see the
Queen to d3 has a merit that it
attacking the c4 pawn my opponent
defended elegantly with fluke to c3 so
not only defending the born but
attacking the Queen so I play Queen to
d2 and again the Queen extent has been
offered which again has been declined
and I play Queen to g4 and now my
opponent plays look to see one so idea
is very very simple now why desperately
want to push the pond but here I place
rook to d2 attacking the Queen and now
again my opponent offer the Queen trade
and this time I accept that so I take
the Queen and when white we capture I
snap up that pole and here I think we
both we're in the time trouble because
we have less than 30 seconds in our
clock opponent place c5 and please note
last few moves are not - made accurate
but still in a time pressure I managed
to win this game so I played a very
casual and a bad move which which is
hooked to f7 and here my upon capture
the pawn I recapture and now he give me
this check and after I put my route back
he plays rook to c7 I played g6 and
after he plays rook to d7 so which has
an idea of putting this roof on this
line or probably capturing this phone I
decided to challenge that rook with rook
to epsilon here
my opponent giving me this cheque and
after King to g7 he grabbed the pawn
I played group 2d to try to maintaining
the pressure on the D pawn but as I said
that we both were in the time trouble so
he played this horrible move which is
rook to e6 and afterwards the game is
very simple I capture this pawn and
after this true again attacking the pawn
I played this move Jason took to a4
after captures captures and rook to e7
I simply played b6 and hear my opponent
lost on time but even if he didn't lost
on time you can see black has a two
passer on the Queen side and if one pair
of fluke has been exchanged this can be
a very easy game for the black
now the tar game features when white
blocks the check with his own Bishop so
for example here instead of Knight to c3
in one of my game
my opponent plays Knight to f3 and when
I give this check with Bishop to b4 my
opponent block with Bishop to d2 well if
your opponent block this check with the
bishop then our plan of campaign will
become more easier because we are simply
going to snap up that Bishop white
recaptures with anything like Queen or
the night let's say in the game my
opponent capture the night we can play
d6 first of all stopping any C file and
after s3 played by my opponent so he
doesn't want this night to be pain we
have this amazing move which is night 2
at 6:00 and you can see instead of
Knight to f6 we can play this night 2 at
6:00 just because white dark square
bishop has been exchanged and now Knight
2 at 6:00 we'll provide more venom to
their file so let's see how this game
programs so my opponent plays Bishop to
b3 I castle on the King side and he did
the same and now comes the f5 so now you
can see this time 3 pcs are joining for
their fight so my opponent capture this
and I recapture with the bishop and here
he D captured and I captured with the
night so now this Knight has arrived on
a wonderful square with F I hear my
opponent plays Knight to h2 so now he
wants to put this night on this g4 but
nevertheless I put my undenied on the
wonderful square which is night 2f files
look at those knowledge they are
wonderfully placed and
there are something nasty happening soon
hear my opponent responded with Queen to
g4 which is pretty immature because here
I can kick the screen we touch fire my
opponent plays Queen to f3 I again had
as this queen with Knight to h4 in the
game my opponent plays queen back to d1
but after very simple Knight H cross g2
and my upon responded here Knight to f3
so he was stopping me my queen - coming
to the g5 square but I found another way
so I played Queen to eard so now I want
to go to Queen to g6 and again want to
give some discovery to the white king
here my upon responded with Queen to d2
I played Queen to g6 anyways and my
opponent puck is king in the corner so
King to s1 but here I simply play E for
so attacking the white light and the
night goes to the d4 and here I simply
capture the pawn and you can see you
already black has a very very wonderful
position please note black cannot play
root 2 G 1 because Knight to Knight
cross F 2 is coming so in the game my
opponent decided to play f3 first of all
and when I played night 2 H for
attacking that pawn one more time now my
opponent decided to give me the exchange
so he played
to g1 but here I simply plays Queen two
at six and I think again in this game he
was in time from the high wasn't and
that's why I played this cunning move it
first side it looks like black has given
up the Queen and my opponent immediately
captured the screen but after night to
f2 this is a checkmate you can see how
easy and effective plan if black can
able to exchange the dark square bishop
with the white now the second move which
I want to consider here is Knight to f3
which has a might of attacking the pawn
but it doesn't stop our routine plan
which is Knight to g6
in this game my opponent was much higher
rated he was twenty two hundred plus and
the chess cube he responded with Bishop
to c4 which a kind of veered Moo but it
has a venom of pushing that pawn further
nevertheless I continue with the Bishop
to c5 so you can see in c4 line because
White has open up the C file that's why
the Bishop to b4 looks very logical but
here why it has not committed the c-4 so
that's why this time it's very useful to
put this Bishop on c5 anyways my
opponent goes for the naked attack so my
opponent plays Knight to g5 it has a
merit of pushing that pawn and attacking
the f7 but I just block that pawn so I
play d6 and my opponent responded with
castling on the Kings side and here I
play Knight to f6 which has a mite of
first playing at 6 and then grab this
pawn so my opponent wisely played Knight
to c3
anyways I place a 6 good side is knight
or the bishop can be stopped at the b5
and the main idea is this bishop it has
been attacked then it can goes back to
de sel hear my opponent plays Bishop to
b3 so he wants to swap up my bishop I
place at 6 and hear my opponent capture
the bishop and I recapture and my
opponent plays Knight to f3 here I play
Bishop to g4 so I am pinning that night
my opponent responded with s3 and I
captured at night and after white we
capture with the Queen I simply castle
on the King side my opponent will
responded with a 4 and I responded with
Knight to f4 so again more you put the
knight on f4 you will see his potential
the one way I can describe this Knight
to f4 is a pain in ass to your opponent
because in this game my opponent
responded with rook to d1 and I played
night to e 8 so that is very simple
I want to block that d6 with my knife
so my up upon responded with Luke to d2
when I played Knight to d6 and that has
a matter of attacking the bishop so
Bishop drawbacks to the a2 now I played
pin to g5 so idea is very very simple
I want to capture that point with the
check and then I can grab that row so my
opponent wisely plays rook to d1
protecting that rook and I played F I so
you can see this turn of campaign hasn't
been changed and we are very much
consistent to were King side attack
blonde hear my opponent capture that
pawn and after I recapture with rook my
opponent lashed out with Knight to e4 so
attacking the Queen here I played Knight
takes good night and after queen
recaptured I think probably he
completely overlooked this attack so
here I played night check and after King
to h2 which has a merit of attacking the
knight I simply played Knight receptacle
and as a maid of attacking the Queen and
the rook here my opponent first of all
plays d6 so I discover attack to my king
and after I play King to h8 he played
Queen to c4
this is a outright mistake why
here comes why so very simple is Queen
to h4 check and after Kings to g1 white
is simply checkmate
the third move which I want to cover is
the move f4 and there has been played
many time when I played 9:27 here the
best replies you capture the phone and
after a white recapture with this you
play Knight to g6 so which has a mallet
of attacking the bishop please note the
bishop cannot go to the e6 because very
simple will be Queen check and the e
pawn will be trouble so white reply has
been pretty much forced so white has to
play Bishop to g6 and now we are going
to play Knight to f6 so which has a
merit of attacking the pawn now if your
opponent is feeling very aggressive then
he might want to try this move which is
e Phi but this is a losing mistake
because the very simple repetition is
Queen to e7 attacking that pawn and
let's say white defend it with Knight to
f3 then the very simple idea is Queen
check and after Knight - D - we can
simply snap up the D pawn
and there are so many tears over here
first is Queen can capture this pawn
also the night to III is in the picture
and please note black image with a pawn
up so this is a very wonderful position
for the black so if I is bit premature
in one of my game my opponent responded
with Bishop to d3 and here I played
Bishop to c5 this is pretty much force
please remember in this line whenever
white plays f4 it's a very good idea to
place this Bishop on c5 rather than
before because Bishop to c5 it's
stopping y2 castling on the Kings side
my opponent continues with the Knight to
c3 and I responded with the d6 and now
he plays Knight to f3 and here I Castle
on the Kings side and now my opponent
plays Queen to e2 so probably my
opponent is feeling aggressive so he
wants to castle on the Queen side and
attack me on the Kings side but
nevertheless I place rook to e8 so I'm
pressurizing more on the Ipoh and now
hear my opponent castle on the Queen
side and I played Bishop to b4 this is
very amazing that this one moves turns
out very very strong for me in the game
my opponent responded with Queen to d2
but after very simple Knight cross e for
white lost pawn so here my opponent
continues with Bishop takes Knight and
rook takes he plays rook to d1 but after
very simple rook takes rook takes I
played Bishop to d7 he responded with a
three attacking my bishop the bishop
drop packs to the fr and after King to
be Val I played Knight to e7
pressurizing the d5 pawn and here my
upon responded with Knight to g5
and he completely overlooked my the
smooches Bishop takes Knight and after
Queen takes I simply grabbed another
pawn and after very simple Queen to d2
Bishop to c6 and Knight to f3
I simply play Queen to d7 and after
Knight to d5
I place rook to e8 and I clearly merge
with the 2.0 and in fact I won the game
very very easy
the tar game which I played with my
friend among VVD
is rating on chest comm is around 1700
which features the move Knight to c3
so here when black capture the ball and
after white we capture Knight to g6 and
Bishop to g3 and black this pawn with
Knight to f6 instead of power Bishop
last game Bishop to d3 in this game
among plays Knight to c3 here the plan
of company is very very simple we are
going to pin this knight in this game
multiplied with Queen to d4 attacking
the bishop but we simply capture this
knife and please note Queen cannot
capture this bishop because the epon
will drop so my opponent has to
forcefully capture this pawn with the
b-pawn and now I pray d6 here he give me
this strange check which is Bishop to b4
check and after Bishop to d7
he played Bishop to d3 so he can argue
that my Bishop has been misplaced
but anyways I castle on the Kings side
and after Knight to f3 now comes the
wonderful moon which is Knight to h4 so
attacking the bishop and if that has
been allowed then the white pawn
structure will be very very shaky in the
game Umang plays Bishop - f - I played
Bishop to g4 so attacking the knight and
my opponent is pointed with h3 and I
kept to the night and after white
recapture for all this exchange you can
see this squares have been very very
weakened and I explored this very
magnificently so first of all I played
Knight to e5 trying to get some cheapos
with Knight cross f3 so among place
between to e3 and I pressurize that
point one more time with Queen to f6 and
after Bishop to e2 here comes our
trademark move which is Knight to f4 and
see those Knights they are wonderfully
placed in the game one castle on the
Queen side so he wants to attack my King
on the Kings side but after a very
simple Knight cross c2 Queen cross a2
and Queen cross f3
I clearly emerged with a pawn up and
please note why it has a double pole on
the Queen side so after a long struggle
I managed to win this game that is how
you can handle if you open and place
Knight to c3 probably the most
aggressive reply by the white is this
move which is as for at first sight it
looks very weird but it has a very
cunning idea
so if black wants to put the knight on
g6 then white can immediately kick that
night and if the position remain block
for the black then isn't the white game
is very good well against this there is
a one theory of the chess which says if
your opponent is playing on the flank
you should play in the center
this is the case of one of my game this
game I have played with my friend on the
way he does not have any feeder rating
but his strength is around 17 to 18
hundred plus and here I responded with
Fi
and he is pointed with Knight to c3 and
after Knight to f6 he pinned that night
with Bishop to g5 anyways I played
Knight cross he 4 and after Knight cross
he for F cross e 4 he plays Queen check
so his idea is very simple he wants to
weaken my king side and after very
initial g6 he plays Queen to e2 so
gaining back the pawn on e4 and when I
place d6 he plays a very wonderful
movement but fall side looks very
threatening
he plays edge fire here I thought for a
very very long time and I come out with
this move which is Queen to d7 the idea
is very simple when white captured the
night and after black recaptured and
when white goes for the hill so why it
takes this pawn so please note my H pawn
is pinned right now but black has a very
cunning idea which is going to g4 so
Queen to g4 is attacking the Queen but
the big idea is to recapture the pawn so
in the game o capture the Queen
recapture with the bishop he plays G
cross at 7 so why does a pawn on at 7
but is this pawn weaker or stronger that
can be shown in the game in the game I
played King to f7 and after Bishop to e2
I simply drop my bishop back to f5 and
after Bishop to h5 check King to g7 now
you can see my three pcs are attacking
that porn
if the point has been taken by the rook
the bishop will dip in so wisely Oh drop
back the bishop but after a very simple
recapture I emerged with a superior
position please note black has a bishop
pan and finally I managed to win this
game so that is one game which highlight
how you should handle if you open place
aggressive move or the sidelines move
such as h4
the last move which I want to consider
is Bishop to e3 and this was played by
one of my friend on Jesco he is a very
strong attacking player now the idea
behind this weird-looking move Bishop to
e3 is that when black responded with
Knight to f6 white will play f3
so that way white is right now blocking
those Knights why it wants to create the
spawn chain as you will see the game
progress and crime the black pieces now
let's see how we can progress from here
so I played Knight to g6 as per our
routine theory and he responded with c4
so as I mentioned white wants to create
this very amazing pawn chains and here I
responded with Bishop to b4 check and
after Knight to c3
I simply capture this night and after
white we capture here I place d6 in the
game my opponent responded with b3 this
is I think probably the best move of the
white the simple reason is if the bishop
comes to d3 then acts like a
sophisticated pawn but if d3 has been
played that means this Bishop can go
either to g2 or to h3 look at this
g2 lf3 they are limiting this line to
come to the either this three squares so
all in all this is a very wonderful move
after long thinking I responded with
Kesling on the Kings side and after my
opponent plays Bishop - G - I played H
Phi here responded with Knight e - and I
played h4
and probably he is afraid of opening up
on the kingside because he wants to
castle on the kingside so he decided to
block the Kings side with the move g5
but now comes a very good tactic so I
played s3 so attacking the bishop and
when the bishop captured the pole
I simply captured the a pawn so nitro c4
so idea is very simple when white
recapture with the F pawn I get this
check and after King goes to the d2 ID
again my piece so now I'm attacking the
g4 my opponent responded with G file and
now I place Queen to h4 so attacking the
lose equal my opponent defended with
night to g3 and now I place Knight to f4
our trade map oh and now this is
threatening the capturing the gee-pole
so my opponent is obliged to capture
this night and after queen recaptures my
apparent pace King to d3
but after very simple queen cross g4 you
can see why peen is truly caught in the
center and not only that black emerge
with a pawn up I hope I have given
enough information to make you confident
that when you open and place d5 and grab
more space you should be happy that he
is allowing you to go for the King side
attack
just grab this opportunity and go for it